world of RC remote control not the cola
is a family fun hobby that allows you to
drive and race high performance radio
controlled Vehicles JC is live at
Friendly Hobbies with the latest how you
doing JC
hey Kendall I'm in heaven out here a
friend a friendly Hobbies uh this is the
grasshopper this was the iconic RC car
of the 80s if you had this in your
neighborhood you were the king of the
block and its back isn't it you were the
coolest kid yes they've re-released all
the new Tamiya kits you can go to your
childhood and rebuild
have fun with it but as also too RC cars
have come a long way these are
incredible cars we have out here super
technology and we want you to take a
little
ride on okay the one there at the end
hit that one down there at the end that
is the fastest car
70 miles
three miles an hour how long does the
charge last or something like that half
an hour half an hour yeah and how long
to charge it back up
about an hour and it lands on it lands
on all fours it's really a fun car and
you see we're out here on the track
today we've created a family destination
the track is open we've repaved the
track we put the fence up come on over
get a car we'll let you use our cars get
on the track have fun there's a lot of
stuff to do here at Friendly Hobbies 3D
printing drifting we had a drifting car
land stand up behind you there is a
Dodge Viper is that a Dodge Viper that's
drifting around that's cool we have a
drift track next door really beautiful
drift track like I said there's so many
things to do here at Friendly Hobbies
what am I going to drive this what is
this this is this the starter car we
talked about earlier
I just hit the drifting car went right
over it but this is this is the new
starter car I told you about everything
in the box under 300 battery charger
goes for about a half an hour I mean I
can do this all day long in this thing
I'm trying to hit the jump oh it hit the
jump spin around here oh watch out here
we go off the Jump
boom it's an RC car you flip it back
over here
we got a track Marshall over here it's
friendly Hobbies I gotta toss it to
break more in Las Vegas now is coming up
next